[Musique]
bonsoir vous retrouver pour ce nouveau
7,8 les invités voici les titres jeudi
dernier l'université versailles saint
quentin en yvelines a débuté son cycle
de conférences sur la thématique du
genre quatre rendez vous sur l'égalité
entre les sexes et les discriminations
sont programmés jusqu'au mois de mars
rencontre avec nathalie pigeard mikko
responsable des ressources historiques
du musée curie
mais nous déboutons ce c'est huit
invités avec le conseil citoyen de
guyancourt créée cet été à l'initiative
de la mairie
le but de ce conseil citoyen remonter
toutes les informations pour en former
un front améliorer la vie de quartier
qui composent la ville alors à quoi sert
le conseil citoyen nous sommes avec gaza
laisser bastia bonsoir vous êtes élue au
conseil citoyen exactement alors dites
moi un petit peu plus alors le conseil
citoyen c'est un conseil qui a été créée
donc enjoint de 2016 et donc nous les
représentants les élus avons été élus
pour cinq ans de 2015 à 2020 d'accord on
a été installé par la mairie du en cours
donc grâce notamment à l'adjoint
monsieur morton et
arrosez cateau movac qu'on remercie
particulièrement pour cette installation
qui a été une bonne organisation
le conseil citoyen pour résumer la chose
en gros je résume c'est un organisme de
concertation
c'est à dire que nous sommes un peu les
représentants de des citoyens les nous
avons été élus pour que les citoyens
viennent nous nous alors comment ça se
passe vous allez à la rencontre des
personnes qui vivent au point de retard
parce que là votre première mission
c'est là et vous récoltez beaucoup
d'informations exactement en fait ce
qu'on avait fait dernièrement c'était le
diagnostic en marchant
donc le diable le diagnostic en marchant
c'était à la rend assez tu es allé à la
rencontre donc aller directement sur le
terrain à la rencontre des citoyens et
de faire un diagnostic justement des
difficultés que l'on peut retrouver au
pont du rotor notamment à guyancourt
donc voilà c'est comme ça qu'on essaie
comme ça que ça avait débuté et pourquoi
la mairie a décidé de mettre ça en place
au mois d'août c'est nécessité de faire
ça alors de c'est une décision de l'état
donc si vous voulez globalement c'est
une décision de l'état et notamment de
la préfecture qui qui demandent
justement l'installation de concitoyens
dans les villes de france et donc on a
eu sa à guyancourt
il ya eu actuellement 850 conseil
citoyen qui ont été créés l'objectif
c'est de passer à 1500 conseil citoyen
en tout donc c'est l'objectif de l'état
est donc c'est pas c'est pas la mairie
on est
si vous voulez on a été installé par la
loi donc c'est une loi de programmation
sur la cohésion sociale et voilà tout et
c'est vous qui
gérer en fait la machine et après vous
remontez ça à la mairie exactement on a
eu on a su vous voulez eu que des
débriefings justement donc j'avais cité
l'adjoint et et c'est comme ça qu'on a
été installé puis ensuite on au nom
d'une organisation autonome si vous
voulez donc petit à petit on va
travailler pour la co construction du
projet de ville la goncourt bon on va
voir un petit peu comment fonctionnez
vous êtes combien et comment moi citoyen
guyancourt toi je peux venir vous voir
alors comme en tout on est 36 on a été
on est 24 titulaire et 12 12 suppléant
je fais partie des titulaires notamment
avec d'autres élus et alors on
s'installe lentement mais sûrement mais
ce qu'on aimerait faire c'est justement
être être à la portée des citoyens
peut-être les qui nous viennent nous
rencontrer justement à des occasions que
nous nous créerons à cet effet là et
qu'ils poseront leurs questions et nous
leur fournirons leur réponse justement
grâce à la mairie qui nous aura un coût
de madame que vous aurez des réunions
c'est ça ou ça et là on a des réunions
on a des réunions la dernière réunion
était une une assemblée plénière donc
tout le monde était tous les élus ont
été convient convié pardon pour
justement discuter installé conte ses
citoyens avec de vraies bases des bases
solides pour ensuite avancé justement à
la rencontre de début en cours tant qu
alors j'imagine que chacun a un rôle
dans le conseil citoyen alors ça j'en
viens il a été il a été récemment créé
trois branches
donc si je puis dire trois branches dont
des animateurs qui vont tourner au fur
et à mesure pour pour qui et pour qui
est du changement
je cite notamment moi qui fais qui est
en ce moment animateurs de la cohésion
sociale
lana dispositif de réussite éducative
pour le plan du rotois on a également le
la branche du travail donc tout ce qui
est recherché d'emploi et la dernière
branche qui est le cadre de vie donc
chacun à un animateur attribuer un
suppléant est un groupe qu'il dirige
pour justement si je puis dire jouer sur
plusieurs fronts à la fois quoi alors
quand vous avez entendu parler du
conseil citoyen pourquoi vous avez
décidé d'y aller mais écoutez moi comme
d'autres comme les autres élus on
s'intéresse énormément à ce que fait la
ville pour but en cours notamment est ce
que fait la mairie et nos conseillers
municipaux et c'est à la suite de
enfin c'est après avoir entendu qu'on
pouvait nous mêmes être acteur justement
des bienfaits de la ville et notamment
de quartiers en difficulté que je me
suis dit baba pourquoi pas le pourquoi
pas y rentrer et justement vraiment
faire quelque chose être acteur du de la
chose ok on est là pour finir elle est
une dernière réponse dans un an qu'est
ce que vous espérez avoir pu faire pour
le pont du rotois alors là je les
importants une minute dans un an c'est
vrai que tout va vite j'ai on espère
simplement bien s'installer en crée la
chose pour que les futurs conseillers du
donc tu conseilles citoyens puissent
eux-mêmes oeuvrer à ce qu'on aura déjà
commencé et qu'ils puissent continuer
par la suite les personnes du compte du
raw thouars ils sentent que c'est une
bonne chose ce qu'ont ces citoyens ils
vous accueillent bien écoutez si je suis
là aujourd'hui
enfin ce soir avec vous c'est aussi
justement parce que on a envie de
médiatiser la chose histoire que les
citoyens prennent conscience qu'il y ait
un conte ses citoyens qui on peut
compter sur nous et sur sur la mairie
pour justement régler tous les tous les
tous les petits soucis du quotidien quoi
et bien en tout cas merci je vous
remercie de nous avoir usé le message a
été entendu et j'espère on prend
maintenant la direction de l'université
de versailles saint quentin en yvelines
la structure a débuté jeudi dernier son
cycle de conférences sur la thématique
du genre
quatre rendez vous sur l'égalité entre
les sexes et les discriminations sont
programmés jusqu'au mois de mars
le premier rendez vous était centrée sur
marie curie et les femmes de laboratoire
notre journaliste michael ennemis droit
rencontré nathalie pigeard mikko la
responsable des ressources historiques
du musée
alors je suis à l'université de
versailles saint quentin en yvelines et
je suis avec nathalie api janicot qui
est responsable des ressources
historiques du musée curie ingénieur
cnrs docteur en épistémologie et
histoire des sciences
elle va présenter cet après midi à
l'université de versailles saint quentin
en yvelines
une conférence sur marie curie alors
nathalie en quoi marie curie at elle
marqué l'histoire
à marie curie a marqué l'histoire de
fait puisque la première femme à avoir
reçu deux prix nobel est la seule femme
à avoir reçu ces deux prix nobel mais
aussi elle a été consacrée en 1995 par
son entrée au panthéon avec son mari
pierre curé et pourquoi avoir choisi
justement de présenter cette conférence
ici à verser 50 ans du lean pourquoi
avoir choisi présentes à cette
conférence
parce que je pense qu'il est très
important de montrer un autre visage de
marie curie de l'arrêt ou humaniser de
sortir d'une image d'icône de façon à
lui redonner son rôle plus de modèles
que d'exception on parle peut-être de
féminisme aussi comment on voit la
carrière de marie curie est ce que vous
êtes d'accord
marie curé et surtout un modèle pour les
mouvements féministes mais n'est surtout
pas une féministe en elle même parce
qu'elle a été de sa vie
par les engagements qu'elle a eu
au sein de la science par le fait
qu'elle s'impose comme véritables
scientifiques dans une communauté
majoritairement masculine par la
reconnaissance historique justement
qu'elle a eu dans ces domaines là elle
peut servir sa vie peut servir de modèle
de féminisme dans le sens où elle l'a
mené comme elle l'entendait et non pas
comme la société de l'époque aurait
voulu qu'elle la mède a éventuellement
et qu'on va se décomposer justement
cette conférence à cette conférence va
d'abord se décomposer en plus tôt en
trois grandes parties à savoir montrer
l'image qui a été véhiculée sur marie
curie à travers les biographies comment
cette image est en contraste avec la
vraie marie curie et enfin l'impact que
cette image construite a eu sur
justement la définition d'un seul et
unique profil qui se voudrait d'une
femme en sciences à son époque mais
aussi aujourd'hui marie curie peut
exister sans pierre et marie curie
existe sans pierre ça c'est sûr mais la
découverte qu'il est qu'il a promu au
rang historique n'aurait pu se faire
sans pierre la découverte c'est pierre
et marie curie pierre-curie n'aurait pas
pu la faire salle marie-curie n'aurait
pas pu la faire seule avec le silicone
vraiment elle n'a pas qu'elle n'a pas
cassé les codes parce qu'on avait besoin
quand elle est arrivée de personnes
qualifiées et elle répondait à ce
critère et quand il ya un besoin
économique son marché du travail
on se moque un peu de savoir si elles et
les femmes si elles et polonaise
elle est compétente c'est quand il ya
des crises économiques là on se rappelle
qu'il y a à sec ce qu'il y a une origine
géographique
par contre elle arrive à un moment de
l'histoire où elle va pouvoir faire une
très grande découverte avec son mari et
cette découverte va être sanctionné par
un tout nouveau prix puisqu'elle
pré-nobel n'existe que depuis deux ans
qui vont les propulsé sur la scène
publique
donc il ya comme ça des qs il y à des
paramètres à prendre en jeu qui
expliquent l'histoire va sanctionner
telle ou telle personne et pas tel autre
ou telle autre personne
et qu'est ce que vous aimeriez que les
gens retiennent de cette conférence bah
déjà que justement la situation des
femmes des immigrés dans une population
est totalement liée à l'état social
économique de cette population que
l'histoire n'est pas linéaire et que
c'est moins le sexe de marie curie qu'il
faut retenir que plutôt son parcours en
tant qu'être humain et vous irez vous
inspire avoue marie curie elle m'inspire
surtout cette cette faculté qu'elle
avait d'aller au bout de ses idées de
les défendre en matière scientifique et
je trouve dommage qu'elle ne l'est pas
faire d'un point de vue social mais
d'avoir su dire c'est moi qui les fait
danser un an dans une communauté
scientifique élitiste très fermé pour
l'époque
merci beaucoup n'étaient lit quoi je
pourrais être conférence merci beaucoup
c'est la fin de ce site 8 les invités
bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]